time to do some spring cleaning now a
big donation drive underway for a brand
new store that a summerlin mom just
received the keys to her goal to rebuild
hope for those who need help
it is actually a dream come true we
first introduce you to nicole lee in
november as she was gathering warm
clothing items for those in need and now
this mom of three just received keys to
a building she's going to turn into a
store for people to get what they need
for free i can't even put it into words
how excited i am nicole knows what it's
like to fall on hard times i know how
those people feel out there
growing up not having the the money that
my friends had she and a friend are
going to open the store in february
calling it rebuilding hope a way we
could bring hope back into their lives
for domestic abuse victims veterans
homeless teens anyone who has fallen on
tough times she needs gently used
clothing and donations various items and
everything you'd think of to open a
store if you know any stores that are
closing anybody that you know is getting
rid of racking hangers
um that's stuff that we're really in
need of right now
volunteers we can't do this without
volunteers we need help right now for
the month of january to sort through
everything
accepting donations this sunday you can
stop by the new store location 2975
south rainbow boulevard sweep b from
nine to two this sunday but you can also
get in touch with them on their website
to schedule another time
rebuilding hope dot vegas